ce qu'on entend par américanisation
c'est à dire qu'en gros on sait ce que
souvient de paimpont certain nombre
d'entre nous se souvient ce qui est
arrivé à gary hart en 1988
tout à coup on révèle dans les journaux
pendant la campagne présidentielle qu'il
trompe sa femme et en gros on voit tout
à coup non seulement la presse lui
demander des comptes est ce qu'il trompe
vraiment sa femme lui demander de
démissionner on voit la classe politique
le le condamner aussi pour ses mensonges
et ses agissements et c est ce qu on a
vu ça avec dans la ferme à la hongrie
volvo cars est en fait non pas du tout
puisque en réalité c'est lui qui a pris
la décision personne de le questionner
mais personne ne lui aurait même le
président de la république le dit qu'ils
le soutenaient qu'elle quoi qu'il dise
voilà donc on est à l'opposé de ce que
on peut enfin de ce que vous appelez ou
de ce qui a été appris la mairie de la
nation et et je rejoins mon mot enfin
bret de valdo voilà tout à fait dans ce
qu'il dit c'est à dire que en effet ce
gouvernement et sa façon de fonctionner
ne pourrait pas se maintenir en place
si on était aux états unis parce qu aux
etats unis le mensonge est vraiment la
chose la plus ignoble et ignominieuse
mais vous faites allusion à d'autres
mensonges l'apa ou mensonge bien sûr non
mais tiers par rapport à faire non ne
pense sûrement c'est à dire que lorsque
vous avez un président de la république
qui affirme il n'y a pas de violences
policières
il est dans le déni de la réalité il est
dans le déni de ce que yahoo ce moment a
prévu dans cette infinité souvent dans
le déni n'a rien sur on le met pas en
accusation pour autant c'est vrai mais
d'un poignant fin du point de vue des
campagnes quelle qu'elle soit si vous si
on découvre que vous
enfin vous êtes dans une enfin aux états
unis on est vraiment dans une forme de
puritanisme sur la vie privée est donc
là on est fan on va vous demander des
comptes
[Musique]